intifada is an Arabic word which
literally means shaking off but it's
most commonly associated with two
Palestinian uprisings against the
Israeli military occupation the First
Intifada started the 1987 when hundreds
of thousands of Palestinians engaged in
strikes boycotts and most iconically
stone-throwing
against the Israeli occupation forces in
the violence that ensued over 1,000
Palestinians and more than 100 Israelis
were killed then following the failed
Oslo peace process the Second Intifada
ignited after Ariel Sharon's provocative
visit to a sacred Muslim shrine central
to the israeli-palestinian conflict
following a brutal crackdown on
Palestinian protesters by Israeli
security forces the Intifada took a more
violent turn with a hundred and thirty
five suicide bombings carried out
against Israeli targets ultimately over
3,000 Palestinians and over 1,000
Israelis were killed
you